our other top story today a busy
intersection closed off for hours after
a deadly crash thank you for joining us
at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Brian
Loftus now it happened just before six
this morning right near Smoke Ranch and
rainbow Victoria Saha joins us live
confirming a garbage truck was involved
Victoria
the investigation still remained the
scene of this impact was so significant
it had those nearby shaken up
a car mangled and a Republic Services
truck banged up the crash taking the
life of one person inside the car well
look like explosion you know because you
know I see some I'm panic because you
know all the time this candlest street
is very bad drivers according to police
the Republic Services truck was coming
out of an alley when a 2010 Infiniti hit
the truck the outcome catastrophic It's
just sad it's pretty sad what happened
you know now somebody didn't make it
home and none of these should happen to
anyone I reached out to Republic
Services they confirm a driver was
involved in an accident and was not
seriously hurt they are cooperating with
the investigation
arriving medical Crews were not able to
save the driver of the infinity no one
else was in that car reporting live near
Smoke Ranch and rainbow Victoria Saha 8
News Now